hey guys Pete here are you ready for
another installment of the pudding peak
season one rewatch I know I am it's been
a while since I've been away I'll tell
you more about that at the end and
before we start I do have to remind you
that this series the twin peak season
one rewatch is brought to you by my
patrons on patreon they support me there
so that I can put these videos out and I
want to thank them and let you know that
at the end you can find out more about
that if you want to so today we're going
to talk about episode three of season
one at Twin Peaks it's the fourth
episode because the pilot doesn't have a
number and it's also known as rest in
pain
like I do with all my Twin Peaks rewatch
videos we're gonna go over the log lady
intro that was added after the fact in
this one Margaret tells us there is a
sadness in this world for we are
ignorant of many things yes we are
ignorant of many beautiful things things
like the truth so sadness and our
ignorance is very real the tears are
real what is this thing called a tear
there are even tiny ducts tear ducts to
produce these tears should the sadness
occur then the day when the sadness
comes then we ask will the sadness that
makes me cry will the sadness that makes
me cry my heart out will it ever end the
answer of course is yes one day the
sadness will end so this episode which I
said was titled rest in pain first aired
in 1990 on April 26th it's interesting
because this is the first episode that
was not written by series creators Mark
Frost and David Lynch and it was not
directed by David Lynch either
regardless it's still a solid episode
and it's kind of interesting looking
back to see how closely they match the
feeling of the other episodes with a
different writer and different director
the episode primarily focuses around
Laura's funeral which we see at the end
but it starts off with Audrey Horne
waiting for agent Cooper before
breakfast it's pretty clear now that she
is interested in the special agent and
we see that he is in a
hurry because he has things to do they
sit down though and he has her write her
name and he realizes that she is
certainly the person who slipped the
piece of paper that said Jack with one
eye under his door two nights previous
Audrey says that it was her that put it
there and she explains that even though
she wasn't friends with Laura she
understood her better than the rest
coupe asks more about when I Jackson
Audrey basically tells him what it is
it's a brothel up north where men go and
we hear about the connection between
Laura and run a Pulaski both working at
the perfume counter at horns department
store which is owned by Ben Horne
Audrey's father this makes us think that
they may have worked at one-eyed Jack's
together and perhaps it is tied into the
ending of Laura Palmer's life the pace
of the episode is quick and we see
sheriff Truman and Lucy walk in and we
see coop tell Audrey she has to go Harry
Truman is all the way interested in who
the killer of Laura Palmer is but coop
does what coop does and he tells him
about a dream and eventually they find
out that coop doesn't remember who the
killer actually is he does detail what
happened in the dream the night before
in the previous episode and nobody seems
really that and frankly Truman and Lucy
don't really know what to think about
coop and his dreams at this point he
explains to them though that his dream
is a code that needs to be broken and he
says that our job is simple break the
code solve the crime Koopman sheriff
Tran would have to head over to the
morgue because they find out there's a
fight going on between Albert and doc
Hayward Albert wants more time with
Laura Palmer's body he has all sorts of
tests that he wants to do but the
funeral is set and the time has already
thought out so they want to take the
body and they don't want Albert to
continue Robert says you can have a
funeral any old time you dig a hole you
plant a coffin eventually this is the
final straw for Harry Truman he punches
him in the face he also Albert also ends
up on lowers body Cooper has some
restraint here he doesn't really say
about the scuffle and he tells Albert to
release Laura's body to her family over
at the Palmers house Leland is being
medicated and he's preparing for the
funeral probably taking a sedative I
imagine we see invitation to love again
the daytime soap opera
we only saw the intro before but we get
an actual scene here and it's kind of
funny because we see that it stars
Selena Swift as twins emerald and Jade
which is making fun of something that
daytime soap operas always used to do
which was have the same actor or actress
you know play a double a twin an evil
version of themselves if you will and
right at the same time we see Sheryl Lee
who plays Laura Palmer come back into
the series but she has brown hair and
glasses and is now named Madeline so I
like that their how they they show that
that's a funny trope or whatever you
want to call it that soap operas do and
then they use it themselves right away
and you can't really fault them after
that because they've already made fun of
themselves the scene at Double R where
we see that Hank
Norma's husband who's locked up is gonna
be getting out of jail after that Cooper
and Truman go to talk to Leo we did have
the scene in the last episode where he
hit the bottle and it broke whenever he
was throwing the rocks on it got to
Leo's name but he just Stonewall's them
for the most part won't really say
anything to incriminate himself after
that there's a really kind of
interesting scene at the Briggs
household at their house we see Bobby
he's kind of standing in front of a
crucifix checking it out sort of holding
his arms up and major breaks comes in
and he tries to talk to him give him his
fatherly advice which never really gets
too far with Bobby and at the end he
says Bobby don't be afraid and that sets
him off Bobby says that he's gonna turn
it upside down speaking about the
funeral after that Albert gives his
autopsy results to the sheriff and agent
Cooper we find out that Laura was on
cocaine that she actually had it habit
he also says that two different kinds of
twine were used to tie up Laura and Ron
and that Laura was tied up twice that
night and at one point her arms were
pulled back
Cooper remembers from his dream
sometimes my arms Bend back we also find
out that Laura had distinctive bites and
marks on her shoulders probably from a
bird and then there is also a small
object with the letter J on it found in
her stomach
Albert after Truman leaves asked coop to
sign a report that he wrote about
getting punched and he basically says no
he says with your behavior towards these
good people you're lucky I don't fall
apart on you that buries you so deep in
a building in Washington you never see
the Sun I guess that just furthers the
connection that agent Cooper has with
twin peaks in these matters obviously
he's supposed to back up his FBI
co-worker but he feels that Albert
deserves what happened to him the short
scene was headed Nadine they're getting
ready to go we see that Nadine is all
over ed and she's loving him James comes
and she acts like she doesn't know who
that is and all we get here is that
James says that he can't go to Laura's
funeral and he takes off at the funeral
it's pretty amazing if you think about
how many times you see so many cast
members together in one place and it's
like never so pretty much everyone is in
attendance
Johnny Horne finishes off after the
Reverend he gives you know his sermon or
whatever and Johnny Horne yells out amen
Bobby keeps true to his word and turns
it upside down he screams amen and he
says you damn hypocrites make me sick
everyone knew Laura was in trouble but
we didn't do anything all you good
people want to know who killed Laura you
did we all did and you know Bobby's
being kind of a douche which he is often
in this first season but he's kind of
right at the same time even though James
says he wasn't gonna be there he did
show up and this little outburst by
Bobby sends him to fighting he takes a
shot at Bobby and then one of the most
memorable scenes in the episode I think
is we see Leland jump on top of the
coffin which malfunctions and
going up and down as he's crying there
we see Sarah Palmer's say don't ruin
this - and it's a very Twin Peaks kind
of scene and that's what I was saying
earlier it's surprising that Frost and
Lynch didn't write this episode but that
they pulled this off in kind of a twin
piece way and it's funny but it's also
really sad obviously because this guy
just lost his daughter a little later we
see Shelley re-enacting what happened at
the coffin to a group of old guys and we
see that Truman Hawk and Big Ed are
there and they're meeting with Cooper
and they're gonna let him in on the
secret which Truman says when Peaks is
different a long way from the world
there's a sort of evil out there
something very very strange in these old
woods call it what you will a darkness a
presence it takes many forms but it's
been there for as long as anyone can
remember and we've always been here to
fight it the men before us the ones
before them the ones after we're gone so
he's talking about the book house boys
and they're gonna let Cooper in on this
and we see them after that go to the
headquarters the book house they pulled
up a janitor from the Roadhouse Bernard
Renault he's tied up and he is the
brother of Jacque we met previously they
found him coming across the border he
had an ounce of cocaine on him and
they're trying to lean on him to get
closer to what's going on in town we
know that Laura's on coke we know that
this guy's crossing the border with
cocaine we know that when our jax is
located near the border somewhere so
that is that we catch up with jock he's
calling Leo Tom and he needs to take a
border run and then we see that Shelley
has brought a gun home and she hides it
so she can defend herself if Leo comes
at her with the soap and the sock again
later we see coop at the cemetery he's
just there hanging out we actually see
him run into dr. Jacoby he comes he has
flowers he tells Cooper that he doesn't
really care about the lives of any of
his patients they're all just a paycheck
for him except for Laura and that she's
the one who made him care again
and but he cared so much he couldn't
bring himself to come to the funeral
that day he says I hope she understands
I hope she forgives me and this is the
first time I guess you could say that we
see that there's more to this character
Jacoby he's not just a weirdo not just a
guy who wears funny clothes whatever and
that is that we catch up with Josie who
is telling Truman that she thinks that
Benjamin Horne and Catherine Martell are
trying to kill her if she dies Katherine
would inherit the mill and then she
could sell it to Ben Horne for the
development deal Josie adds that she's
sure that they killed her husband Andrew
Packard and we see sheriff Truman swear
that he's not gonna let anything happen
to her and I think the point here is is
that that you know he's really taken by
her and he'll do anything for her
she is got his number or whatever you
want to say the episode finishes off
with another creepy Leland seen over at
the Great Northern
we do have an exchange here with Cooper
and Hawk where he asked him if he
believes in the soul Hawk says several
he talks about dream souls that wander
and different things there
kind of establishes the connection
between coop and Hawk and then we see
like I said Leland is on the dance floor
he gets excited when a song comes on and
then he gets upset because he can't get
anyone to dance with him the big thing
from this little exchange I think is
Hawk talks about dream souls that wander
and find themselves in a distant land of
the Dead and Cooper asked him is that
where Laura is to which Hawk responds
Laura's in the ground agent Cooper
that's the only thing I'm sure up so
this was a good episode like I said not
quite as essential as the other episodes
in season lon maybe but definitely solid
like I mentioned this the first one the
Frost and Lynch didn't write it was
written by Harley Peyton he wrote quite
a few of the later episodes and in the
second season I guess he was responsible
for some of those twists and turns it
was directed by Tina Rathborne who
hasn't done a lot of stuff beyond
she actually directed a movie that had
David Lynch in it it was called Zelly
and me she directed this episode and
then she directs one more episode later
on and after that she did not do a lot
of work in the business I tried to find
some interesting facts about this
episode and I didn't come up with too
much I did read that the name of Laura's
identical cousin Maddy is Madeleine
because it's a nod to Alfred Hitchcock's
vertigo there was a character there
played by Kim Novak that was named
Madeleine ester and Judy Barton so if
you're Hitchcock fan you might have
already known that and the other thing
is like I said earlier that this is the
first time that we see most of the
principal actors of the series together
and it's also the last time there's
really not another scene that has this
many of the main characters altogether
so that is that I'm happy to be back and
I'm happy to be back on season 1 I'll be
doing another one of these next week so
definitely check that out I had to do
some things to pay some bills and I've
been away but I am back now I'm in
between shows at the moment so I'm not
sure what my content is gonna be but we
could go more in the Twin Peaks
direction and gets through season one
and into season two if that's what the
patreon patrons wanted to do you could
check that out at the link at the top or
at the end of the video and if you loved
Twin Peaks it's a good way to get a
little bit more of it while we're
wondering if there's ever gonna be
another season please like the video if
you enjoyed it make sure you subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
make sure you turn on notifications
after that because you won't find out
about my videos if not think about
coming and joining us over a patreon we
can talk about different shows that are
coming up that we might want to get into
and I would love to have you there
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon